hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round 10 of the
20/20 online nations Cup by bifida
inches calm its Fabiano Caruana versus
one cow both of them participants of the
twenty20 candidates tournament and it's
a very interesting they will be
repeating one of their games from the
candidates tournament and well it's very
important for the standings to see if
the United States will be able to
qualify for the super final and also
since on board one Hikaru Nakamura
already lost his game to Dingley and so
now Fabi definitely needs a winter to
equalize or more so without further ado
let's check it out Fabi with the white
pieces opens with E for and I I didn't
think I'd show any more games from round
10 but we kind of forgot to mention the
standings in the previous video and when
I say we I mean me so that's also one of
the reasons why I said sure but also
it's just a very nice game so e5 Knight
f3 Knight of six the petrol of defense
the same heat as he played against
Fabiano in the candidates tournament
Knight captures on e5 the main line and
now d6 kicking back the night with
Knight to f3 and now Knight captures on
e4 and he ran Knight to c3 the names of
each attack against the petrov same as
Fabi played in the candidates tournament
against long--how Knight captures and
see 3d characters and the Bishop to e7
so far everything the same both players
just keep on developing Bishop e3
castles and Queen to d2 preparing
queenside castle we have Knight to d7
and just win side castles here we have
Knight to f6 and Bishop to d3 now so
everything exactly the same as in the
candidates tournament
c5 and rook ht1 now fabi's pieces have
been fully mobilized and Bishop to e6
von Kahr still needs to develop the
rooks and he will also complete his
development and here in the candidates
tournament Fabi went for this King to be
one line where after Queen a5 this the
Queen's got traded off and so on but
here Fabi prepared Bishop to f4 for this
game and it's it's a new move so already
has a move 12 we have a completely new
game and now it's a long house turned to
see what this means or doesn't mean for
the position obviously we've introduced
another attacker to the d6 pawn which is
which is a weak bond for the moment but
as Fabi decided not to bring his King to
say Foursquare or or or place c4 for
that matter d5 is a possibility here so
on-call takes this opportunity to play
d5 he doesn't wanna be left with the
weak d6 pawn so nice the g5 by Fabi and
here comes as the bishop is under attack
Bishop to g4 now it's it's interesting
why Bishop to g4 and this is one of the
weirder moments of the game at least for
me here the engine suggests for example
c4 and after the bishop moves then you
just move the bishop to d7 now I don't
have a problem with Bishop to g4 but
it's weird because we have castles of
opposite side so by playing Bishop to g4
and attacking this rook you are forcing
f3 and the white wants to play f3 even
if you don't play Bishop to g4 white
wants to play f3 may make some support
for g4 play h4 h5 g 5 and so on so by
playing Bishop to g4 it just seems weird
but the help Fabi start his expansion on
the Kings side but okay we have three
and now Bishop back to d7 so maybe now
after the bishop comes to c6 and let's
say five he pushes g4 maybe the idea is
that the f3 pawn will be a target but it
just looks a bit weird
yeah but okay we have c4 now by Fabi not
allowing c4 by black so his Bishop
remains and this diagonal and now d4 not
preparing to bring this Bishop over to
c6 to grab hold of this diagonal with h4
Fabi starts expanding on the Kings side
and now rook to e8 and g4 now
so the f3 pawn really doing a nice job
in helping the expansion with Bishop to
c6 now okay this pawn is a target if for
example h6 maybe you can get rid of the
knight and wind up on but we have Queen
to h2 and now it's a question what what
really happens if h6 is played now can
you just remove can you remove the
defender of the f3 pawn and maybe grab
this pawn the idea is that if you play
h6 here then there are a lot of
interesting tactics like you can play
Bishop to c7
but also just the knight characters on
f7 followed by g5
busting open the position seems like a
possibility so instead of h6 we have
Queen to a5 just going after that a to
pawn and Fabi now needs to react you
don't have time for any any craziness on
the Kings side
so here it's between King B 1 and a 3
Fabi decides for a 3 instead of moving
the King and now push it back to f8
adding one of one more defender to the
g7 pawn and also now preparing to trade
rooks along the e-file Fabi first goes
Bishop to d2 kicks away the Queen Queen
to b6 and now Queen to f4 now you don't
really worry about h6 but here we have
Bishop to d7 back by one call and now
it's a problem because now
well his position is just lost so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
it the idea Bobby Bobby played now well
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on not playing Knight
captures on f7 this is what I thought
but it's not because if Knight captures
King characters in g5 then black has
this very nice Bishop to d6 now you kick
away the Queen and the knight will be
free to move since the Queen cannot
remain here at the pin to keep pinning
the night so instead we have Bishop
captures on h7 now this is the correct
idea also congratulations to everyone
who found it and also to those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
point is that if it's captured then you
get Queen captures and f7 King h8 and
Queen h5 and there is no preventing
checkmate you your only hope is Queen h6
but then just night f7 check and you
pick up the Queen so instead after this
up to h7 check we have king to h8 and
now comes at Bishop back to f5 now again
with the threat of just Knight captures
and f7 check remaining and the black has
the black has to figure out how to deal
with this so first how captures on a5
with Queen captures on f5 and now King
back to g8 keeping an eye on the pond
the night covers h7 so there is no
checkmate
and here again while you could capture
on f7 it's too early for it because
again after King captures g5 then you
have g6 and now again you don't have a
wood square for the Queen
you go back here then just Bishop to d6
again is an option so here you would
have to settle for character scout for
some characters and just play the same
game being up a pawn of course white is
still better but Hobby Lobby can do
better so instead he doesn't like the
idea that after Knight sacrifices that
black can play g6 so here Fabi first
prevents g6 by playing h5 and now the
threat remains of Knight captures on f7
and along how it could try something
like Queen c7 to keep an eye on the pawn
then let's say Bishop f4 and then Queen
d7 to trade Queens and then go into the
same so this is a possibility however
how played Queen to c6 and now our Fabi
just goes for it but black seemingly not
interested in the attack but okay Fabi
goes for it Knight captures an f7 wave
King captures and only now g5 and here
how played Queen to d7 now offering a
trade of Queens so if you captured the
night the Queen is hanging on f5 but
here Fabi said okay no problem I'm just
gonna play Queen to g6 check and it was
in this position unmoved 28 at one-car
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it's the king is in
check you have to move the King and once
you move it the G captures on f6 is
coming and just everything falls apart
for black not much not much point in
playing this for example if if Queen f7
just trying to trade Queens you can just
go F captures and g7 and it's a it's a
pretty bad position but she captures on
g7 you can go Queen back to g5 now you
can bring the rock over here push h6
it's unplayable and Ivanka knows this so
after Queen to g6 check he resigned the
game so really really exciting stuff and
so I don't forget in this video here are
the results of round 10 so as you can
see Russia defeated India with two and a
half to one and a half we've seen the
game artemyev versus with it that brutal
attack and also under 18 defeated
Audubon China lost to the United States
dinkler and defeated Hikaru Nakamura on
board one but then Fabiano caruana in
the Wesley so I defeated one cow in you
young E and you and Jun and Irina crush
drew their game and we have a draw
between Europe and rest of the
world with future defeating Iranian and
young shift of Duda defeating Bassam
Amin so that's for for the results of
round 10 but also here we have the
standings after 10 rounds so as you can
see China in the lead with 17 match
points followed by USA in Europe with 13
points both but USA has 22 additional
points those are board points and Europe
only 21 and a half so by half a point
margin USA is qualified into the super
final so now we will have United States
against China in the super final of the
nations cup which we are of course going
to cover some of the games the nice ones
of course so you know feel free to use
hashtag suggestion if you if you spot a
nice game I will also do my best to keep
track of them so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Raphael Bordeaux Christian hammer
Doug Hughes in 1998 and she rock metal
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Nations
Cup until it ends so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday